chess go starcraft
and now protein folding i'm john coogan
and today we're talking about deepmind's
pioneering work in artificial
intelligence
and what it means for the future the big
news that i want to cover today is about
deep mind's alpha fold 2.
the short version is that back in
november of 2020
researchers at deepmind created an
artificial intelligence program
that solved the protein folding problem
which has plagued biologists for over 50
years
the long version is much more
interesting though so stick with me here
while i cover some background on the
company
as well as the protein folding problem
itself the whole story here is super
interesting because
while this is clearly some of the most
advanced technology humans have ever
created
there is really very little consensus as
to what the impact of this will be
over the next decade let's dive into it
deepmind was founded in 2010
specifically to try and build a
purpose ai that can be useful and
effective for almost anything
they quickly brought in some of the most
high profile investors
including peter thiel and elon musk
after just
four years in business google bought
deepmind for 500 million dollars
but the structure and goals of the
company remain largely unchanged
despite being a for-profit enterprise
deepmind has focused on developing
ai systems that can win at common games
they started by playing atari games and
quickly surpassed human abilities there
and in 2014 they moved on to the
strategy board game
go go has been played for more than two
millennia
and many go experts thought it would be
impossible for a computer to ever
beat a world champion go player this is
because go is an extremely complex game
although the rules are simple a standard
go board
is a 19 by 19 grid which yields more
legal positions
than there are atoms in the universe
simply put
it's impossible for any computer no
matter how powerful
to calculate every potential move and
then determine the best strategy
the best go players have amazing
intuition for what strategies will
work and computers have historically not
been able to develop
real intuition but deepmind had a new
approach to this problem called deep
reinforcement learning this can get a
little bit confusing
but it's actually fairly simple if we
break each piece down
learning means that the designers of the
system will not be manually defining the
features
that the program will optimize for
essentially the system
learns what's important to pay attention
to from the raw data directly
reinforcement means that the system will
learn by experience
instead of by example this means that
you don't need
to provide the system with examples of
what a correct answer looks like
instead you provide a goal called a loss
function
that the system optimizes towards and
lastly
the deep part refers to the fact that
the system has multiple layers of
neurons that serve to predict
outcomes this all mimics the way humans
learn in the real world
our brains have neurons that fire
electrical signals that help us perceive
the world and intuitively
understand cause and effect this
approach also lends itself well to games
because games have a clear goal that the
algorithm can optimize towards
winning and games can be simulated
extremely quickly in software
so when deepmind trained its deep
reinforcement learning system on go
it was able to play millions of games of
go in a very short amount of time
and this approach worked in 2016
deepmind's artificial intelligence
alphago
beat the world champion lee sadal in a
five-game match
the go community was shocked by the
performance of alphago
over 60 million people watched the match
and lee sadal
who had predicted that he would win in a
landslide said that he misjudged the
capabilities of alphago
and felt powerless it wasn't long before
deepmind tackled the even more complex
game of starcraft 2
which is unique because the player
doesn't have perfect information about
the pieces on the board
like in go and the game is played in
real time
deepmind's alphastar system defeated two
professional starcraft players
in 2019 using the same fundamental
approach of self-trained artificial
intelligence
as their alphago system while it's
certainly a great demonstration of
computing power
winning a game doesn't have all that
much practical value
and that's where the protein folding
problem comes in proteins underpin
every biological process in every living
thing
each protein has an intricate 3d shape
that defines
what it does and how it works biologists
have cataloged over 20 million proteins
but pinning down the exact shape of
these has been extremely difficult
each protein is made up of a string of
amino acids
interactions between these amino acids
make the protein fold
leading it to find a particular shape
out of essentially limitless
possibilities
for decades scientists have been working
on a way to deduce a protein
shape just from its amino acids this is
one of the major challenges of our
understanding of biology
using a similar approach to their go
system deepmind trained a new network on
the 100 000 or so proteins that we do
know the shape of the results of
deepmind's latest system called alpha
fold 2
are really remarkable the efficacy of
these protein folding systems
is measured by what's called the global
distance test and alpha fold 2 scores
remarkably high
a score above 90 is considered roughly
equivalent to the true
shape and should be usable by
researchers and alpha fold 2 has
essentially reached that threshold
this is important because determining
the shape of proteins
is extremely useful to biologists and
experimental techniques are expensive
and time consuming
most estimates put the cost of solving a
single protein shape
around 120 thousand dollars and it
usually requires a full year to do it
having a tool like alpha fold could
speed up work being done in biotech and
help researchers understand more about
diseases
it's a huge step forward a big part of
what enabled the jump in efficacy
between alpha fold one and two
was switching the core technology from
convolutional neural networks
to transformers both of these models
still fall under the broader deep
learning category
but transformers are unique in that they
can effectively simulate
attention just like a human openai's
gpt-3 model produces remarkably
realistic natural language results using
transformers
and the approach has clearly been
spreading quickly throughout the deep
learning community
but at the end of the day alpha fold is
just a tool
so i want to be clear about the
implications here and make sure we
aren't getting ahead of ourselves
part of what makes all this possible is
that potential protein structures can be
simulated very quickly
not unlike simulating a go match when it
comes to testing different drugs in
human patients
these approaches are unlikely to be as
effective we don't have a way to
simulate the full biological system that
makes up the human body
so you can't just test millions of
different drug candidates
in seconds on a computer that being said
this tool is going to speed up a lot of
work
and it will almost certainly have a big
impact on the lives of researchers
now that doesn't mean that this research
can't produce entirely novel results
not by any means there is a great moment
during alphago's match against lisa doll
that i think can be really instructive
here
in game two the ai made an extremely
unexpected move that no human
player would ever think to make lisa
doll was completely taken aback
and actually left the room to take a
break and think about what just happened
it seemed like an error and the
announcers were confused as to why
alphago would make that particular
decision but after playing out the
entire game
alphago won and that unpredictable move
proved to be effective
and this is what i think is so powerful
about these new ai systems
they aren't just taking human strategies
and performing them with more clinical
precision
they are actually developing new
strategies altogether
since alphago beat lee sadal several top
go players have trained with the ai
and improved their game significantly
and gary kasparov
the chess master who was defeated by
deep blue in 1997
has said that a good human plus a
machine
is the best combination my hope is that
these artificial intelligence systems
can work alongside humans to develop new
strategies
that humans wouldn't think to consider
that's the real promise of this
technology in my mind
but what about the threat of ai last
week i talked about how
elon musk had been watching deepmind's
progress and was worried about ai
becoming
sentient and taking over the world it's
a true doomsday scenario straight out of
the terminator
but fortunately we aren't quite there
yet these ai systems are still in need
of
lots of data and are purpose built for
very specific tasks
the economist recently covered
artificial intelligence in their
technology quarterly
and highlighted a number of headwinds
that ai must still overcome
these include the difficulty of
collecting data in the real world
the high cost of training each model and
unpredictable human factors
while it's certainly possible that
humanity will eventually face an
existential threat from artificial
general intelligence
i think that weaponized ai can become
destructive
far sooner than it can develop sentience
as i covered in my video about the solar
winds hack
cyber security is increasingly becoming
a primary battleground
where world powers wage war ai enabled
hacks could wreak havoc on critical
infrastructure
and there's always the potential for
these viruses to spread beyond the
creator's initial target
the stuxnet worm was originally aimed at
iranian nuclear facilities
but it wound up infecting over two
hundred thousand computers
still we are clearly in the early stages
of ai development
the progress is exciting but it's still
narrowly applicable
self-driving cars are not yet widely
available and voice assistants still
routinely fail to answer simple
questions
so i think we should press on and
continue to push ai as far as we can
so how does all of this pertain to
startups well there are a few things
that i can think of
first there's been a lot of discussion
about breaking up big tech companies
elizabeth warren led the charge from the
left while peter thiel and josh hawley
have led it from the right generally
startup founders fall into two camps on
this issue
on the one hand if you break up google
they might be easier to compete with
and startups could potentially get
bigger faster
but on the other hand without massive
tech companies it would be hard to land
billion dollar acquisition offers like
we've seen with waze
instagram and whatsapp returning to
alpha fold
if deepmind's solution to the protein
folding problem actually has the
practical applications that many people
think it will
it kind of makes the case for not
breaking google up
this type of work is extremely resource
intensive and it doesn't
look like academic institutions are
anywhere close to matching the results
of alpha fold
having a big tech company that is
willing to pour billions of dollars
into research initiatives that may not
turn a profit seems like a good thing on
balance
but we'll have to wait and see the issue
of antitrust in big tech is extremely
complex
and will have to be the subject of a
future video but i want to know what you
think
let me know in the comments what you
think about deep mind and alpha fold
and if you enjoyed the video please
consider subscribing to the channel
i've also put together a playlist of
other great videos about deepmind that
you can check out in the description
thanks for watching